invité de preuves par 3 françois
rebsamen le sénateur maire socialiste de
dijon bonsoir mon frein d'être avec nous
vous avez de grandes ambitions pour
votre parti bien sûr pas seulement dont
en 2012 mais dès cette année en 2011
vous voyez la gauche devenir majoritaire
au sénat
c'est possible possible c'est impossible
votre probabilité ces personnes aux
derniers calculs il paraît que vous
faites des calculs très précis
il ya tellement de facteurs qui entrent
en ligne de compte gérer une chance sur
deux skanska déjà bien alors d'accord
bon on en reparlera au cours de cette
émission trois parties évidemment dans
un instant quelques questions
d'actualité avec vous et puis françois
d'orcival de valeurs actuelles et du
figaro magazine nous rejoindra pour
aborder la question de la sécurité
pouvez-vous vous seul françois rebsamen
contredire ce reproche d'angélisme qui
souvent adressé au parti socialiste sur
ces questions et puis perrine tarneaud
de public sénat sera là pour le dernier
quart d'heure pour des questions plus
personnelles et puis on fera
connaissance avec le françois rebsamen
des débuts a le militant à moustache on
verra ça bien avant votre arrivée à la
tête d'une ville réputée bourgeoise où
vous avez été brillamment réélue la
gauche demande donc la démission de
michèle alliot marie qui au conseil des
ministres a reçu un mot de soutien
apprend t-on de nicolas sarkozy est-ce
que vous jugez le chef de l'état trop
faible incapable de virer c'est la
question que je me pose
vous me la poser mais c'est la question
que je me pose aussi parce que il avait
promis une république irréprochable et
on a plutôt la république des
intouchables pour le moment on a
effectivement une ministre qui est en
grande difficulté non pas pour des
raisons politiques mais parce qu'elle
s'est enferré dans des mensonges
successifs que cette affaire continue en
permanence je suis pas sûr que le
président de la république soit très
heureux de cela on peut faire passer les
messages qu'on veut qu'il a fait passer
des messages mais c'est pas bien c'est
l'image de la france qui est dégradée
elle est ministre des affaires
étrangères
bref je pense qu'effectivement le mieux
serait qu'elle démissionne le mieux
serait qu'elle démissionne au moins il y
aurait une fois puisqu'on parle de
sécurité au moins il y aurait une fois
une sanction est le mieux serait qu'elle
le fasse elle même alors lll dénoncé en
retour l'abjection du parti socialiste
l'avait entendu oui moi j'ai pas
d'habitude de demander démissions de
ministres c'est vraiment je suis plutôt
quelqu'un de deux modérés mais là tous
les jours ce que pense que ça ça nuit à
notre pays on n'a pas besoin de cela et
cette image n'est pas bonne pour la vie
publique le mélange des affaires
publiques privées c'est jamais bon alors
vous dites que l'image de la france
s'est dégradée cette diplomatie
également entamé mais celui de
l'international socialisme que si
toujours michèle alliot-marie la
tendance le socialiste qui a gardé dans
ses rangs jusqu'au bout benali mêmes
hosni moubarak du moins son parti c'est
vrai c'est vrai la france
enfin le parti socialiste français a
demandé plusieurs fois leur exclusion il
le demande encore c'est une machine
vieillotte l'internationale socialiste
elle est composée de partis qui ont le
nom du socialisme et qui ne sont pas à
oui je me dis que l'internationale
socialiste
on pourrait presque dire la même chose
peut-être du parti socialiste non sur un
point sur certains points à montoir et
ça mais maintenant je ne le dirai pas
demander un changement d'identité du ps
comme a pu le dire manuel valls j'ai
contribué à moderniser avec d'autres
bien évidemment la déclaration de
principes du parti socialiste d'un parti
social-démocrate et qui se reconnaît
dans les valeurs et
cette fiche identitaire du parti
socialiste tient un tonique à la droite
accuse le parti socialiste d'entretenir
la polémique pour masquer son absence de
projet son absence d'idées de
propositions est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
peu devrait écouter sur cette affaire
moi je préférerais qu'on parle
effectivement croissance développement
économique pouvoir d'achat chômage
on pourrait renverser l'argument je
pourrais très bien dire à cause de cela
on ne parle pas des vrais sujets qui
intéressent les français c'est la presse
qui tous les jours cent des nouvelles
annonces concernant michèle alliot marie
elle aurait ni tous dès le début on n'en
serait sûrement pas là mais à force de
dire des petites choses et puis des
choses contradictoires dire je suis pas
ministre
quand je suis lent en vacances puis je
suis ministre 365 jours sur 365
bref on ne sait plus très bien donc pour
moi je pense en plus elle ne peut plus
représenter dignement je crois la france
dans les pays du maghreb avec son
comportement avec ses mensonges
successifs
voilà moi je suis désolée pour elle mais
c'est comme ça oui je pense vous avez
évoqué un conflit d'intérêt sans doute
en raison de la dimension immobilière de
deux de ses vacances familiales en
matière de conflits d'intérêts elle a
menti sur tout c'est ça qui est quand
même gênant cet homme d'affaires
tunisien il n'était pas là par hasard
comme elle l'a dit à la descente de
l'avion
elle y allait parce qu'elle allait en
vacances mais il savait les relations
immobilière il semblerait à moi je
connais pas tous les dessous de cette
affaire je vous avouerai qu'elle me
passionne pas ce que je vous dis c'est
que je pense que c'est pas bien pour une
mise la sphère d'étrangères de partir en
vacances comme ça on tunisie alors tous
les jours on a un nouveau feuilleton
grâce ou à cause de la presse c'est
comme vous voulez pour vous ce sera
quand même hein
le regretter quand même la qualité du
débat non mais je pense que cette
affaire aurait dû être réglé depuis un
bon moment elle aurait dû dire la vérité
à ce moment-là président de la
république aurait pu prendre ses
responsabilités là où traîne cette
affaire à chaque c'est chaque semaine et
on a autre chose à faire que cela donc
moi je souhaite qu'elle démissionne
vous avez parlé d'un conflit d'intérêt
la concernant donc en matière de
conflits d'intérêts le rapport sauvé
préconise vous le savez un certain
nombre de règles strictes de
transparence pour tous les élus mairie
de la fin de certains cumulent par
exemple ministres et patrons d'exécutifs
locaux demain si vous êtes ministre de
l'intérieur imaginant cela on ne peut
pas et vous vous abandonner sa maison
vous abandonnez dijon il ya eu je
répondre à cette question plus tard
plus tard c'est quelqu'un qu'on
administre dans quelques instants
je vous dirai ce que j'en pense mais il
ya eu plusieurs réglementations en la
matière on a connu un ministre de
l'intérieur comme gaston defferre qui
était en même temps maire de marseille
on a connu un ministre qui était d'une
droiture total qui n'avait plus de
l'exécutif local pierre joxe
on a eu des règles posées par lionel
jospin qu'on pouvait
comme quoi on ne pouvait pas être
ministre les maire d'une grande ville en
vous moi je ne suis pas encore ministre
de l'intérieur médoc c'est que ces
questions là je me les pose le moment
venu je pense qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
lui adopté une position de principe à ma
position principe est assez simple je
pense qu'on ne peut pas faire les deux
on ne peut pas être un ministre d'un
grand ministère
et en même temps maire d'une grande
collectivité ni d'une petite d'ailleurs
il ya des risques de conflits d'intérêts
très bien françois rebsamen la relance
du débat sur l'identité nationale 1 et
de l'interrogation sur la place de
l'islam dans la république de sa
compatibilité avec la laïcité
est-ce que vous jugez cette relance du
débat par l'ump
jeudi suis aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'elle
relève de ce que vous avez dénoncé
nicolas sarkozy la recherche permanente
de bouc émissaire oui est-ce que la
céleste la recherche de boucs émissaires
moi je suis tenant parce que la laïcité
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
et je pense à tous les républicains de
progrès je veux dire des choses comme ça
c'est c'est le pilier de notre
république
donc je suis tenant d'une laïcité
stricte qui a pas besoin de mettre des
adjectifs cette laïcité
elle doit permettre à chacun dans sa
sphère privée d'exercer s'il le souhaite
la religion de son choix mais sur
l'espace public
je ne suis pas favorable à toutes les
formes d'expression religieuse
j'ajouterai pour être encore plus précis
que je pense que l'islam de france
l'islam de france est compatible avec la
laïcité et la république en tant que
maire d'une grande ville vous aimeriez
pouvoir mieux garantir l'exercice du
culte musulman je les fais à dijon oui
alors j'ai du mal de réponses pour
d'autres oui je peux répondre pour
mémoire dans le cadre de chez 1905
clichés des os des limites
oui c'est vrai les génomes d'ailleurs
cette loi sur cet aspect là on y toucher
c'est toucher quand même un des symboles
de la séparation de l'église et de
l'état
mais il est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
laisser se développer un islam des caves
ça a été dit et c'est juste on peut
aider quand même sous des formes
diverses à la construction de lieux de
culte dignes pour les musulmans c'est ce
que nous avons fait à dijon et je crois
que c'est ce qu'essaie de faire une
majorité de maires qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite
quand est ce que vous êtes opposés aux
minarets comme nicolas sarkozy qu'il
leur ait dit devant des responsables de
la majorité comme marine le pen
également
moi je suis pas opposé à des minerais je
suis opposé à ce qu'ils aient un muezzin
qui viennent chanter la prière sur
l'espace public
mais les constructions la construction
elle-même parce qu'un minaret au début
c'est une construction
elle doit relever des règles d'urbanisme
vainqueur de mener ce projet car non pas
de pas de prières pas de champ sur
l'espace public
d'accord pas de ça hier il n'a pu ni
d'appel à la prière dans l'espace du
absolument parlons de dominique strauss
kahn qui a fait l'objet vous l'avez vue
d'un tir de barrage à droite ces
derniers jours il va parler dimanche
soir ce sera lors du journal de 20h de
france 2 est ce que vous attendez est-ce
que vous lui demander de lever les
ambiguïtés sur ses ambitions françaises
non non papa à l'occasion de l'émission
de france 2 je pense pour en revenir à
première partie de votre intervention
je pense que effectivement les attaques
dont il a fait l'objet
elle montre du côté de la droite d'une
grande fébrilité
une crainte de sa candidature c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut affirmer
ensuite ça me permet d'ajouter que
franchement ce qu'a dit monsieur jacob
n'est pas très digne ou alors c'est
profondément maladroit parce que ça
s'applique exactement à nicolas sarkozy
vous avez d'un côté le maire de
sarcelles ou celui qui l'a été et de
l'autre celui qui a été maire de neuilly
donc comme représentant de la france
rurale le maire de neuilly va que des
difficultés quand vous parlez de
maladresses pas de relent
d'antisémitisme
moi je n'irai pas jusque là je par leur
maladresse pour le moment mais ça
demande à être vérifiée il ya tous les
cas il faut que ça cesse ses parents
mais vous vous accommoder donc de cette
période d'incertitude dans lequel dénia
plonge le parti socialiste nous avons
adopté un calendrier
personnellement j'étais plutôt favorable
à un calendrier plus rapide
oui pour moi plaisir à votre ami
françois hollande non non non non parce
que je pense que c'est l'intérêt c'était
l'intérêt je n'ai à la parfaite c'était
l'intérêt du parti socialiste d'avoir
plus rapidement un candidat mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça dans une formation
politique qu'a choix a été fait le choix
il a été fait de la date du 12 juin
date limite des dépôts et là je me tiens
et donc j'accepte ce calendrier
je ne voulais pas que ma proposition de
calendrier accéléré apparaissent comme
un calendrier anti strauss kahn parce
qu' il ne peut être question il était
simplement pro-hollande peut-être il
était pro il était surtout pro intérêt
général du parti socialiste alors vous
que je pense est profondément par-delà
françois hollande et mon amitié avec
françois hollande mais ça ne peut pas
être ça ne pouvait pas être un
calendrier qui empêcher un candidat de
la qualif pour dominique strauss kahn
alors vous espérer un jour une annonce
de candidature de dsk dont vous vous
estimez en tant que proche de françois
hollande que il est plus utile là où il
est à la tête du service est ce que dit
christine lagarde
votre position non non il est utile là
où il est il a fait du bon travail
aujourd'hui et ici demain dominique
strauss kahn est candidat
j'en serai très content d'accord elle
est là votre position mais je viens de
regrets non mais j'en veux la donner
on examinera la situation on examinera
la situation il s'imposera avoue geste
il s'imposera vous à ce moment là bah
écoutez ce sera un débat qu'il faudra
avoir y compris avec lui voir comment
les choses se présentent comme elle se
prépare comment elles se mettent en
oeuvre etc
je veux pas aujourd'hui rentré dans une
politique fiction il n'est pas il n'a
pas annoncé jusqu'à preuve du contraire
qu'il était candidat
c'est un excellent candidat j'ai quand
même dire des choses tout a très
clairement c'est un excellent candidat
vraisemblablement aujourd'hui il aurait
les faveurs d'une grande majorité de
socialistes en tous les cas c'est ce qui
apparaît on sait qu'il va garder les
faveurs parce qu'on parle d'un homme
providentiel
il subit déjà une chute l'a dans les
bois elle est quand même très mesuré
cette chute sains et il est évident que
quand il va annoncer sa candidature et
il va perdre bien sûr mathématiquement
il va baisser dans les sondages
donc les sondages de bonnes et de
mauvaises opinions je les laisse de côté
pour le moment on verra bien je sais
quelle est la nécessité pour la gauche
c'est d'être présente au deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle et donc
ceux qui m'apportera c'est le résultat
re l'attention de vote que feront les
uns et les autres
mon premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle un mot encore ségolène
royal pour vous ça y est maintenant elle
a passé son tour en 2006 positive francs
genève se finit non elle est là elle est
candidate elle annoncé qu'elle était
candidate voirie les travaux du jeu mais
je pense qu'elle n'arrivera pas à
recréer ce désir d'avenir très bien
allez on va aborder maintenant donc la
question qui vous occupe beaucoup
françois rebsamen dans votre ville bien
sûr mais également parti socialiste les
questions de sécurité
françois d'orcival va donc nous
rejoindre dans un instant mais d'abord
on va voir que l'une de vos fierté et
bien c'est le système de
vidéosurveillance que vous avez installé
dans votre ville même si ce système n'a
pas toutes les faveurs au sein du parti
socialiste
on découvre ce reportage dans votre
ville de fabrice qu'une est difficile de
trouver un bus ce lundi dernier à dijon
après l'agression d'un conducteur les
agents sont en grève
une délégation un rendez-vous à la
communauté d'agglomération
la vidéo c'est clair que ça se
solutionne pas tout puisque le curé qui
se fait braquer les agresseurs étaient
cagoulés donc après c'était plus délicat
donc ils ont trouvé la parade donc nous
demandent des moyens humains très
présente dans les bus la vidéoprotection
et surtout l'une des mesures phares de
la ville de dijon 26 caméras kadri le
centre ville depuis fin 2009 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
coût de l'opération 600000 euros toutes
les images sont traités par le cs eu au
centre de supervision urbain donc c'est
un lieu sécurisé qu'ils se trouvent
à l'intérieur de l'hôtel de ville dans
ce petit local sont traitées toutes les
images de vidéo protection
les opérateurs se relaient en permanence
pour surveiller les différents écrans un
comportement chez les personnes qui sont
susceptibles de commettre d'infraction
il épate à une pas naturel ça se fasse
détecte une formation non non pas de
formation pas de formation spécifique
donc mais un comité d'éthique pour
veiller à la bonne utilisation de cette
vidéo protection
selon les faits constatés policiers
municipaux ou nationaux interviennent
c'est un bon outil de prévention est bon
quand aux aux affaires élucidées grâce à
la vidéo n'existe pas de statistiques
aussi bien disons que dans toutes les
grandes villes de france
en parallèle de la vidéoprotection les
effectifs de la police municipale ont
aussi été doublée et leurs missions
redéfinies
alain millot et le monsieur sécurité à
dijon pardon le monsieur tranquillité
publique
un poste est un service créé de toutes
pièces après la victoire aux élections
de 2001 faut être maître
parti socialiste l'agglo la gauche
peut-être plus largement jusqu'à ces
derniers temps était quelque peu mal à
l'aise frileuse concernant ce dossier
sujet je pense pouvoir dire que c'est de
moins en moins vrai dijon serait le
laboratoire de ce changement
une idée qui fait sourire françois
xavier dugourd le chef de file de
l'opposition ne mâche pas ses mots
contre françois rebsamen et sa politique
sécuritaire
c'est un discours national c'est un
discours national s'il ya une posture
nationale choisi ce thème pour exister
sur la place nationale
on constate qu'à dijon les résultats
sont pas vraiment larmes les mauvaises
langues iront jusqu'à dire qu'il fallait
bien ça pour séduire une ville
traditionnellement à droite mais les
mauvaises langues à dijon sont désormais
surveiller donc
et bien quels sont les résultats que
vous avez à travers ce système de
sécurité non seulement naturellement la
vidéosurveillance mais l'accompagnement
par la police municipale puisqu'on vient
de voir les deux qu'est-ce que vous avez
obtenus depuis donc 2009
alors d'abord je voudrais dire sur
portage est tout à fait juste mais dijon
est classé troisième ville la plus sûre
de france parmi les grandes villes
françaises classement à bouger je dis ça
parce que je viens d'entendre des propos
qui ne sont pas justes j'ai fait venir
dans une grande première la semaine
dernière le directeur départemental de
la sécurité publique devant le conseil
municipal parce que c'est une des
propositions que je fais d'ailleurs dans
le livre sur la sécurité parce que je
souhaite que les élus et nos concitoyens
puissent s'emparer de ces sujets c'est
un élément majeur
donc il est venu présenter les
statistiques alors on peut penser ce
qu'on veut des statistiques du ministère
de l'intérieur
des statistiques qui sont ça permet de
comparer plus tôt plutôt favorable voilà
donc ça c'est pour l'élément sur la
vidéosurveillance jeu
je pense que ça ne peut fonctionner il
me faut quelques instants de
l'explication
ça ne peut fonctionner que s'il ya un
parfait accord avec la police nationale
avec le directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique
car c'est lui qui doit définir les
endroits nécessaires d'implantation des
caméras et il faut une convention est un
accord avec la police nationale
parce que s'il n'y a pas de réponse de
la police nationale quand il ya
nécessité d'une intervention repéré sur
la vidéosurveillance alors c'est pire
que tout c'est pire que tout donc à
dijon le système fonctionne de la
manière suivante la justice le procureur
a été associé à la démarche
le directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique et moi et mon adjoint
à la tranquillité avant accepter les
propositions qui nous avait été faite
par l'ats la police d'implantation des
caméras des 26 caméras ou centre ville
parce que c'est là qu'il souhaitait
qu'elle soit et il ya eu des résultats
mais j'ai demandé justement qu'on est
les statistiques ce qui est dit par mon
agent il est tout à fait juste qui est
des statistiques plus précises mais si
ça n'a servi ça je sais que ça a servi
si ça n'a servi qu'à sauver une fois une
vie c'est ce qui est arrivé une fois
l'année dernière et mis à sac montré son
utilité bien ce voilà ce que je vends en
matière de police municipale depuis
quand y at il de la police municipale à
dijon il y avait de la police municipale
à dijon comme je suis arrivé à la mairie
il y avait très exactement 38 policiers
municipaux et aujourd'hui ils pas énorme
il y en a 66 vous avez effectivement
quasiment doubler les et j'ai
effectivement pas doublé mais quasiment
doubler les effectifs mais j'ai surtout
passé une convention avec la police
nationale
élaborer un contrat local de sécurité de
prévention de la délinquance avec la
police nationale avec le directeur
départemental pour décharger autant que
faire se peut la police nationale de ce
que j'appelle les tâches indues de la
police nationale ça sujet qui me
passionne et parce que quand je suis
arrivée la police nationale faisait tout
et nos policiers municipaux
bon il était là oui pourquoi ces
affaires de police vous passionne autant
on savait que ça même je sais pas c'est
peut-être mon passage au mr dunkerque a
quand même été assez long
resté cinq ans prénommé jack son
ministère donc voila et puisque c'est
aussi mais vous avez envie de
décomplexer votre parti sur ces sujets
là oui ça c'est clair
je pense d'ailleurs que je ne suis pas
le seul maire à penser ça les maires les
maires socialistes sont aujourd'hui
confrontés comme comme les autres
d'ailleur 1 mais les maires qui
appartiennent au parti socialiste sont
aujourd'hui confrontés à ces problèmes
de délinquance qui quitte une aubry mais
elles pourraient pour elle la
vidéosurveillance n'est pas la solution
miracle alors là il ya quand même un des
cas la raison à la raison non je n'ai
pas dit que la vidéosurveillance était
la solution miracle j'ai d'ailleurs
donné or si vale les conditions d'une
bonne application la nominée aux
surveillances parce que si votre
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique qui pourrait arriver demain n'a
plus les effectifs pour envoyer sur les
grosses interventions c'est arrivé une
grosse bagarre et c'est la plus
effective pour intervenir alors c'est un
outil qui peut se retourner contre
contre l'al l'outil lui même alors vous
policiers municipaux qu'elle est
l'entraînement qu'ils reçoivent
est-ce qu'ils sont armés telles qu'elles
sont leurs compétences alors je ne je ne
veux pas les armes et ils sont donc ils
ne sont pas armés et ils sont formés six
mois à en lien avec la police nationale
ce que je pense qu'il est indispensable
mais bon il y en avait qui n'avait pas
été formés et quand je suis arrivé voilà
donc il y avait une ancienne génération
la nouvelle génération qui arrive
elle est formée avec la police nationale
lcl connaissent et hll connaît elle sait
ce qu'elle a à faire
elle a déchargé la police nationale de
beaucoup de tâches qui surveillance des
écoles le matin tout ça c'est pas la
peine soit l'appréciation elle vaut
mieux qu'elles soient sur le terrain
le soir on sait qu'opposer vous avez un
point commun avec nicolas sarkozy
la même passion pour les questions de
sécurité parce que vous êtes aussi passé
place beauvau
oui on encore communiste mais c'est
surtout je crois devoir
la difficulté de vie dans des quartiers
difficiles
la difficulté de vie dans les quartiers
difficiles de voir comment ce sont les
gens les plus modestes ce sont les gens
les plus souvent les plus pauvres tous
les cas les plus modestes les milieux
populaires qui sont les premiers frappés
par cela qui m'a qui m'a obligé est
quasiment en tant qu'élu j'étais
conseiller général avant d'être mère
d'un quartier sensible de la ville de
dijon
donc j'ai vu j'ai vu des gens qui
baissaient les yeux quand ils arrivaient
dans une rue je ne supporte pas ça je
pense que c'est au coeur du pacte
républicain
vous êtes resté comme vous l'avez dit
cinq ans auprès de pierre joxe dont vous
avez cité tout à l'heure la probité le
grand professionnalisme et notamment
donc au ministère de l'intérieur comment
expliquez vous que depuis vingt ans
puisque c'était il ya vingt ans pierre
joxe était ministre de l'intérieur
les chiffres de la délinquance est
tellement exposé explosé et que nous
n'ayons nous ne soyons pas parvenus à
baisser suffisamment cette délinquance
même avec les 10 ans de politique de
droite dans ce domaine pour revenir aux
niveaux que vous avez connu qu'est ce
qui se passe il y a un problème la
société française il ya promenant dans
toutes les sociétés occidentales et une
montée de la violence qui est la
résultante de multi facteurs va-t-on
dire le et il faut les analyser ce qui
se passe de malheureux aujourd'hui je
les dis encore hier dans un débat un
député ump
nous débattions de la sécurité il faut
qu'on arrive à un consensus républicain
sur ce sujet car il n'est pas vrai que
d'un coup de baguette magique
la droite qui l'a fait croire je le
regrette je lui ai dit où demain la
gauche pourra résoudre ces problèmes il
faut du temps et il faut qu'il y ait un
continuum de l'action publique
il faut qu'ils aient un impact sur ce
des grandes formations appelé à diriger
notre pays sur ce sujet il faut le
sortir des enjeux électoraux
c'est le reproche que je faisais je
pense que la droite l'utilisent souvent
à des fins électorales on peut me
répondre non c'est parce que vous-même
enfin vous adresser aussi à votre camp
par le oui oui je fais quelques vérités
il ya des divergences aujourd'hui mais
elles ne sont pas elles ne sont pas
insurmontables
elles ne sont pas insurmontables et en
tout état de cause personne ne peut
faire laisser penser aujourd'hui qu'il
résoudra seuls sans un continuum
d'action se perd ou les sentais proches
de certains à l'ump que d'autres au
parti socialiste on ne me le demandez
pas je me sens très proche de tous mais
oui d'accord oui ou par non non c'est
pas je veux pas dire je suis socialiste
je sais pas je suis pas gêné d'être
socialiste je suis très bien au parti
socialiste et j'ai beaucoup de mes amis
d'alors au parti socialiste
je ne respectais d'autres personnes il y
a eu une affaire toute récente qui a
conduit le ministre de l'intérieur à
réfléchir à la dissolution de deux
compagnies de crs pour transférer les
effectifs de ces deux compagnies sur la
sécurité publique
on sait que les mêmes opérations se
réalisent également dans la gendarmerie
quelle est votre appréciation dans ce
domaine une question qui est qui est
très difficile quand on a pas c'est pas
pour éviter la question quand on n'a pas
tous les outils de connaissance c'est à
dire quand on n'est pas aux manettes du
ministère ce qui est ce qui s'est passé
parce que il s'est passé un recul il
s'est passé un recul c'est que la grogne
montait et m'ont toujours dans la
gendarmerie ou le statut militaire c'est
qu'on ne discute pas les décisions
ces neuf c'est que durban i escadrons de
gendarmes mobiles qui ont été dissous
dans la ville de dijon et est donc de
voir
deux escadrons crs de montagne exercice
de compagnie cette fois ci les
compagnies deux compagnies de crs 10
août a provoqué cette poussée chez les
gendarmes
on le sentait de résistance je pense que
il faut revoir l'utilisation des
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
comme ça je ne tromperai pas des
on peut les utiliser de manière plus
intelligente
est ce qu'on doit en dissoudre
personnellement comme ça je ne le crois
pas personnellement comme cela je ne le
crois pas je pense qu'on peut les
utiliser autrement autrement même
d'ailleurs que pour une sécurisation
ponctuelles parce que la sécurisation
ponctuelle elle a ses effets à un moment
par exemple prenons l'exemple de
grenoble toulouse lyon d'emblème ou lyon
ou marseille
il ya un moment il faut rétablir l'ordre
donc là gendarmes mobiles ou des
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
il faut qu'elle soit là mais elles sont
utilisées souvent dans des opérations 48
heures etc
et ça c'est pas bon ça fonctionne pas
donc il faut réfléchir sûrement un des
formes de territorialisation mais je ne
suis pas aujourd'hui pour dissoudre je
ne suis pas pour diminuer les effectifs
de la police nationale
je ne suis pas pour diminuer les
effectifs la gendarmerie mais vu que je
suis réaliste je considère qu'il faut
arrêter de les diminuer
je propose de sanctuariser le budget des
ministères de l'intérieur parce que je
pense qu'on aura beaucoup de mal à
l'augmenter il augmente mécaniquement
pour des effets qui sont des effectifs
et de rémunération oui de davantage en
hiver en nature qui ont été accordés au
fil du temps est-ce que vous mais pas
pour des raisons d'effectifs vous avez
parlé de la délinquance notamment des
mineurs tout à l'heure est ce qu'il faut
une loi spécifique pour renforcer les
sanctions contre eux comme l'a demandé
le chef de l'état oui ou non
écoutez j'ai non parce qu'ils font leur
une fois peu de réponses une fin un peu
de temps pour expliquer ma position je
pense que c'est pas de loin que nous
manquons aujourd'hui ces deux moyens
dans la justice
je suis très heureux de voir que le
débat s'est ouvert ce sujet à l'occasion
d'un drame d'ailleurs vous ne pouvez pas
faire en sorte de faire suivre 170000
vous m'entendez 170000 condamné par 3000
conseillers de probation et d'insertion
certes reculé en france on met tout cela
oui pardon la contradiction cette
histoire de moyens et la réalité
judiciaire
prenons la seine-saint-denis et le
tribunal de bobigny surchargé oui c'est
refaire surchargées manque de moyens bon
bon il n'empêche que la loi sur la
récidive
apple a prévu des peines plancher pour
les cadres et sidi liste pourquoi
n'est-elle pas appliquée parce qu'il
n'ya pas sais pas mais non et c'est
c'est pas une que les peines des
condamnés
il ya des condamnations sont ils sont
pas laxistes et nogent aulas l'a demandé
il y à des condamnations
mais on ne veut pas appliquer les peines
planchers ces deux sous prétexte que
c'est à l'état non mais il est bien
content pour cent vous le savez bien on
hésite entre 30 et 40% des peines de
prison qui ne sont pas effectués c'est
toute chose mais c'est la même chose
c'est pour ça
n'aura pas permis l'individualisation
des peines et s'il faut aller entre les
envies du elle n'en avait d'ailleurs une
planche et il n'ya plus
d'individualisation dans certains cas et
si ce ça mériterait un débat un peu plus
loin un jour peut-être ici et s'il ya la
prison à faire il faut qu'elle puisse
être faite mais il faut que ça soit
immédiat il faut que la sanction elle
soit immédiat car elle évite la récidive
si elle est immédiate
si elle ne l'est pas est bien le père
son caractère exemplaire et c'est ça qui
entraîne sûrement ce taux de récidive en
particulier notre pays et parfois ces
drames merci françois d'orcival encore
une question à propos des roms
un an après la polémique de l'été
dernier on constate que leur nombre est
resté le même dans notre pays à l'époque
vous aviez soutenu les expulsions
doivent se reprendre quand des gens sont
en situation irrégulière sur notre
territoire
ils doivent être avec humanité traiter
bien évidemment mais doit être
raccompagné à la frontière voilà c'est
clair merci françois nous honore donc
accueillir péri par notre public sénat
mais d'abord on plonge dans votre passé
françois rebsamen ou les lui avec tam
tran huy souvenez-vous l'époque du
militant à moustache au les bonnes
valeurs plus haut de ce beau monde la
bourgogne françois rebsamen lui est
attachée depuis plus de 30 ans c'est au
conseil régional auprès de pierre joxe
qu'il a fait ses armes avant de le
suivre au ministère de l'intérieur
le député didier mathus lui a présenté
son mentor
ensemble ils ont fait leurs études et
travailler place beauvau on n'était pas
tout à fait dans le coloris général du
cabinet du ministre l'intérieur dirons
nous et lui ne l'était pas du tout ils
avaient des tenues vestimentaires assez
différente de celle qu'il porte
aujourd'hui ça y'a pas de doute mais bon
c'était
notre génération et notre âge on aimait
le rock'n'roll la fête et c'est vrai que
ça a dû être étrange pour l'ex membre de
la ligue communiste révolutionnaire de
passer super préfet on se sentait pas
vraiment chez nous parce que pour nous
la police dans les années 70 je dirais
pas que c'était l'ennemi mais en tout
cas c'était quelque chose dont on se
méfiait beaucoup parce qu'on était d'une
génération plutôt gauchistes plutôt
libertaire mars 1989 françois rebsamen
méconnaissable débute sa carrière
d'homme politique
il choisit la bourgogne comme terre
d'élection et se lance à l'assaut de
dijon son ambition à l'époque mettre en
ballottage le maire de toujours robert
poujade dans ce fief de la droite
elles sont déjà loin les vestes à
franges son look ni gauchiste me davy
crockett comme a pu le dire pierre joxe
et des années 70 ne reste que la
moustache qu'il rasera quelques années
avant de devenir maire de dijon
mais j'observe que françois a pris des
positions disons plus sécuritaire que
les miennes nous sommes mer tous les
deux lui d'une beaucoup plus grandes
villes mais je ne partage pas tout à
fait ces options dans ce domaine là
principe de réalité oblige quand on
s'installe dans la cité des ducs de
bourgogne on s'embourgeoise un peu c'est
vrai alors oui je suis comme depuis
toujours
voilà mais ça déteint pas forcément une
ville comme dijon une ville assez
bourgeoise quand même elle n'est pas
aussi bourgeois ce qu'on le croit on l'a
cru parce que robert poujade et on est
resté maire pendant 30 ans mais c'est
une ville avec beaucoup d'ouvriers
il ya un renouvellement de la population
d'une ville comme dijon de 40% tous les
dix ans c'est à dire que vous avez 40 %
de population qui n'est plus la même dix
ans après et je pense que c'est quand
même le premier maire de gauche depuis
les années 30 donc il a fallu un peu
sans doute lycée votre discours
politique pour conquérir la ville
non j'ai fait venir en 2001 la seule
personne que j'ai fait venir en 2001
c'était françois hollande
béja pour montrer que j'étais pour
montrer que j'étais socialiste donc je
ne vais pas cacher pour montrer que
j'étais société mais j'avoue que j'ai
des conseillers à lionel jospin de venir
me soutenir oui vous pouviez et monsieur
poujade eu le mérite aux ricains vague
de la droite de gomes puisqu'il est fier
de votre travail parce qu'on dit qu'il
n'a pas vraiment favoriser une
succession dans son camp politique
on dit ça mais vous allez on aurait il
est fier de vous on en aurait dit le
contraire en tous les cas j'ai des
relations cordiales avec lui donc vous
êtes adoubé par la droite locale
ancien de bras non non non non non le
combat était combat électoral bien sûr
difficile en 2001 ça a été très serré
c'est une bataille donc et robert
poujade s'était retirée mais c'était une
vraie bataille extrêmement difficile
j'avais un adversaire pugnace de qualité
qui est qui avait été président du
conseil régional etc et un adjoint de
robert poujade de ses 52 48 vous savez
en 2001 dans le contexte de 2001 où on
perdait toutes les villes enfin le
socialiste
il fallait à part paris et lyon il
fallait y arriver didier mathus rappelé
dans le reportage votre engagement votre
premier engagement dans votre jeunesse
auprès de la lcr il en reste coi
aujourd'hui il en reste le côté
international je suis très sensible
j'ai été très marqué par le coup d'état
de pinochet au chili par les
interventions militaires de ce que
j'appelais l'impérialisme américain
ces événements politiques internationaux
ils ont poussé très jeune dès
l'adolescence vers la politique voilà
sentiment que des peuples luttaient pour
leur liberté que des 10
erreur cette liberté est donc ce
sentiment reste restant moi j'étais très
heureux de la de la révolution
tunisienne j'étais très heureux de ce
qui s'est passé en egypte voilà j'ai de
découvrir que des dictateurs peuvent
spoliés leur peuple comme ça elle a mené
à la misère je parle pas des tortures et
cetera donc il n'y a rien de plus beau
que la démocratie voilà
et contrairement à d'autres vous ne riez
pas se passer très gauchiste dit
bertrand gille
j'ai changé bien sûr merci je ne crois
plus en tout ça je ne crois plus au
grand soir
ça fait longtemps on m'accuse même même
mes amis comme didier mathus me trouve
sécuritaire mais non j'ai changé mais je
me préoccupe tous là bientôt pour vous
sécréter que venue de votre camp
peut-être peut-être à dijon d'abord non
mais vous savez dix jours des gens n'est
pas une ville où on a besoin de faire
parce que c'est une ville sûre enfin il
ya toujours des problèmes mais c'est une
fille c'est une ville à la première
grève des bus c'est la première en dix
ans c'est il ya toujours des problèmes
mais c'est vraiment faux il faut prendre
conscience
la difficulté de la vie dans certains
quartiers pour des gens modestes brûlé
la voiture de quelqu'un qui n'a que ça
comme outil pour aller travailler
c'est quand même insupportable raison
c'est insupportable les incendies dans
notre pays
voilà on vous connaît au niveau national
vous connais surtout comme l'homme de
l'ombre le numéro 2 d'abord derrière
françois hollande au sein du parti
socialiste et puis après derrière
ségolène royal pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2007 vous maîtres
celui qui active les réseaux qui tire
les ficelles
donc j'ai eu l'occasion j'ai eu
l'occasion à un moment de ma vie a pas
très longtemps de
peut-être de postuler pour être premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
mais je pense et on finit par exemple
c'est une occasion que vous avez manqué
non c'est une occasion où je n'ai pas
voulu me présenter
est-ce que s'arrêter contre ségolène
royal non c'est elle qui me le proposait
donc jeté à le dire ici
crespel d'ailleurs parce que j'estime
pour cette femme et je n'ai pas fait
parce qu'on peut pas être maire de dijon
on peut pas être maire de dijon et
premiers secrétaires du parti société
mon sentiment
il faut y consacrer plus de temps que
cela et j'avais beaucoup donné et
j'avais besoin
je vais pas dire comme lionel jospin
vive la liberté vive la pensée etc
mais j'avais besoin de changer un peu
les idées et je suis très heureux d'être
parlementaire
ça me permet de voir autre chose non pas
d'autres gré de papa c'est un rôle de
premier plan je sais pas si je parlais
je vais rester le maire réseau l'homme
de réseau il est temps vous aussi alors
la question là pour répondez quoi
non non pas spécialement je me suis
toujours passionné pour la la politique
c'est vrai appelons ça donne non j'ai
beaucoup d'amis au sein du parti
socialiste parce que j'étais on disait
que j'étais d'un très bon connaisseur de
la carte électorale a vertement vous
connaissez très bien les fédérations
socialistes jeu j'ai perdu ça de vue je
vous le dis et ça va vite ça ait du
changement heureusement les jeunes qui
arrivent je suis incapable aujourd'hui
de de vous dire ivresse quand même une
certaine intuition non j'imagine au
niveau de la carte électorale du terrain
voilà comment vous sentez par exemple
les choses pour les élections cantonales
je sens une montée puisque vous me
demandez je sens une forte poussée des
partis protestataires à l'occasion des
élections cantonales en zones rurales
essentiellement l'extrême-droite
oui extrême droite jeu sans ça je sais
pas si ça se traduira parce qu une
élection cantonale
c'est difficile de mesurer cela ya pas
des candidats fn partout etc
je sens que
c'est là et on aura quand même quelques
exemples parce qu'il ya des endroits
significatifs en france où on peut
prendre référence à d'autres élections
cantonales pour voir les progressions
les reculs je sens qu'il ya une poussée
qui va de pair sûrement avec le rejet
d'une partie de l'ump de l'ump il faut
dire les choses comme ça disons que
c'est pas très porteur en ce moment le
parti socialiste a connu ça aussi à une
époque c'est pas très porteur en ce
moment d'ailleurs les candidats mettre
l'étiquette derrière eux et puis il ya
une déception je sais pas pourquoi ce
pays
enfin j'ai quelques idées ce pays en
dépression enfin il faut il faut lui
redonner confiance c'est un pays
formidable il a du talent donc une route
et directionnels mais sans doute aussi
une forte abstention et en zone urbaine
une forte assistance sur rue et danse
urbaine une force d'attentions
assurément surtout que c'est la seule
élection
enfin depuis fort longtemps en 1973
c'est la première fois qu'une élection
cantonale ne sera couplé avec aucune
autre élection elle a lieu sur la moitié
du territoire
grâce à vous on en parle mais vous savez
la presse parisienne
quand il n'y a pas d'élection sur la
ville de paris etc on sait en province
c'est parce qu'il a ça sera peut être là
un enjeu pour le sénat peut-être donc
tant mieux ils vont en parler la presse
va en parler à peu
mais bon ça pénétrera pas en profondeur
je crois n'y a pas de campagne nationale
pour aller voter
pourtant c'est un devoir civique voilà
on est confronté à une crise
démocratique
aujourd'hui dans notre pays pour revenir
à la campagne de 2007 vous étiez
derrière ségolène royal numéro deux avec
jean louis borloo jean louis bianco par
didier ben voilà que j'aime bien j'ai de
bonnes relations avec jean louis borloo
serait bien non ce ne sont pas nous
avait essayé sans cesse de colmater un
peu les brèches les lives différence
entre le parti et la candidate qu'elle
le soit il faut en tirer pour 2012
il faut sûrement laisser une plus grande
liberté au candidat ou à la candidate
demain donc y compris sur le programme
oui y compris sur le programme sauf sait
pas ce qu'est prévue la portance un
bipartisme et c'est ce que je pense je
demandais ce que je peux jouer 10 c'est
une bêtise
en tout état de cause il faut que ce
programme ne présentent pas d'aspérités
anti anti sociale démocrate ou anti
réalisme il faut il faut être réaliste
sur l'état des finances publiques
aujourd'hui pas dire qu'il faut presser
de l'espoir parce que pensez vous de
jean luc mélenchon très anti dsk qui
estime que martine aubry est la seule à
pouvoir rassembler la gauche mais qui
s'occupe de son parti jean luc revol a
besoin ici parce qu'ils s'en préoccupe
pas ce qu'il a dit ce qu'il a dit sur
dominique strauss kahn est pas tolérable
je voudrais dire ici est pas tolérable
il a été ministre du gouvernement de
lionel jospin il est ministre quand
dominique strauss kahn était à la
soi-disant d'après demain d'après jean
luc mélenchon c'est elle
le premier ministre le gouvernement le
plus à gauche de toute l'europe y avait
dominique strauss kahn dedans donc quand
même un moment il faut un peu de
continuité dans la pensée quand vous
avez une comparer récemment le chef de
l'état à louis xiv parce qu'ils les
karma carmen l'état peut être trop à
votre goût comment appréciez vous ce
qu'il a déclaré devant des députés ump
le chef de l'état en effet annoncé qu'il
avait fait une meilleure part d'audience
que
le match amical de foot france brésil
l'autre soir sur tf1 et ben voilà ce que
tu es excusez moi s'cusez moi mais cet
enfant ce côté infantile j'aurais dû
dire louis xiv enfant parce que ce côté
infantile je suis de satisfaction
personnelle
il ne parle que de lui vous avez
remarqué il est tout le temps en train
de parler de lui quand il veut dire que
quand il veut faire de la compassion il
dit vous rendez compte comme je suis
comme ça difficile le métier de ministre
et de président de la république
donc c'est je trouve pas ça digne je
trouve pas ça dit pas bien il ne parle
que de lui reproche mon adresse où
beaucoup au leader du parti socialiste à
quelques ténors avec cette fameuse
compétition des égos partager leur
vision à résoudre à un public la voilà
merci on se réclame mais si merci
perrine bonsoir à tous et la semaine
prochaine merci
de 1988 à 1993
le journaliste belge hugues le paige a
réalisé plusieurs documentaires sur
françois mitterrand durant des années
j'avais pu tourner dans des conditions
exceptionnelles pour l'époque
vingt ans plus tard il redécouvre des
images inédites et s'interroge sur
l'étrange relation qu'il avait noués
avec le chef de l'état
un jour sans préavis il m'avait offert
cette séquence dix minutes entre
l'abandon et le retour à son escorte
une fois encore le prince mettait en
scène sa propre image je le savais mais
cet épisode surprenant était une chance
pour moi le prince et son image
samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat
aujourd'hui je perds un ami et la france
perd l'un de ses plus grands serviteurs
la république était le fil de la vie de
philippe séguin ce matin ce fil s'est
rompu et je pense avec émotion à sa
famille un titre bien sûr dominent
l'actualité le terrible séisme qui a
frappé haïti qui commence péniblement à
panser ses plaies à compter ses morts
dans la nuit du 27 au 28 février dernier
cynthia balaye la france et touche
particulièrement la façade atlantique
vous êtes les premiers à venir écouter
les sinistrés qu'il faut quand même
qu'on me prouve que je suis en danger
mortel et que c'est pour mon bien qu'on
détruit ma maison de ouamane you are
waiting for la chica quel moment
et comme je le disais récemment à xavier
bertrand il ya eu de la neige à
carcassonne c'est pas les 35 heures
l'équipe de france de football ça va pas
terrible en ce moment c'est pas les 35
heures suivant la question monsieur le
pen est ce que c'est mais des dernières
élections au niveau des anciens
j'attendrai que le patron sonne le
rappel je crois qu'après le 14 mars
plus personne ne parlera de la bac rose
voilà mais la france est bien en rose
avec un seul point haut à droite c'est
l'alsace le hezbollah doit poser les
armes c'est le message qu'est venu
rappeler gérard larcher c'est un message
d'ailleurs que j'ai dis très directement
et cela peut pas y avoir plusieurs
heures mais dans un pays
notre pays ne peut pas rester immobile
je pense que ce qui se passe dans la
réponse que nous sommes capables de
faire de même
c'est un peut encore amener le
gouvernement réfléchisse monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis qui voulaient bien retirer la
banderole maintenant s'il vous plaît le
sénat a adopté l'ensemble du projet de
loi portant réforme des retraites
le 11 juin 1957 maurice audin un jeune
enseignant de mathématiques à la fac
d'alger membre du parti communiste est
arrêté par l'armée française que c'est
déjà compliqué comment rice avait été
torturé il m'a dit c'est simplement
c'est dur prix c'était le dernier
contact
odin la disparition est un documentaire
exceptionnel sur la quête de ses proches
notamment de sa femme josette pour faire
éclater la vérité
avec des témoignages bouleversants de
pierre vidal naquet henri alleg et
robert badinter jeux furent des années
de le grand combat judiciaire a
seulement judiciaire politique
odin la disparition un documentaire
inédit dimanche à 9h sur public sénat
bonjour a tous rêvé de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de web citoyen au
web citoyen c'est un tour d'horizon de
la blogosphère politique et des débats
qui agitent la planète web et on
commence tout de suite par clic and
sweet
le zapping des vidéos des blogs des
tweets et des initiatives citoyennes sur
le net
qui dit quoi l'internaute a décortiqué
les discours des politiques
le magazine en ligne a passé au crible
les déclarations de 35 personnalités
entre 2000 et 2010
on y apprend que c'est nicolas sarkozy
qui utilise le plus le pronom personnel
je suivis de près par ségolène royal
longtemps promoteur d'une vième
république c'est sans surprise arnaud
montebourg qui emploie le plus souvent
le terme république la croissance une
notion qui revient sans cesse dans la
bouche des politiques
eh bien ce n'est pas christine lagarde
qui arrive à la première place mais jean
pierre raffarin est ce un effet de sa
positive attitude
la polémique sur les voyages de mam et
de filles ont atterri sur le web et des
internautes de se gausser de cette zone
de turbulences ainsi un petit malin a eu
l'idée
créé un site parodique inspiré du
covoiturage cogage étage le numéro un du
partage de jet privé mettant celle mam
fillon benali et leurs amis qui donnent
leurs bons plans pour voyager à moindre
coût dernier avis en ligne celui d'hosni
m qui vient d'embarquer et qui nous
claque la bise le sharman chez les
belges ont décidément le sens de
l'humour pour résoudre la crise
politique qui secoue la belgique depuis
plus de huit mois
l'acteur benoît poelvoorde avait proposé
il ya quelques semaines à ses
compatriotes de se laisser pousser la
barbe
largo nos barbes jusqu'à ce que la
belgique se relève aujourd'hui le site
lesoir donne la possibilité aux
internautes de pousser leurs coups de
gueule sur la toile à travers le belgo
matteau et puis aux grands maux les
grands remèdes
une sénatrice flamande propose la grève
du sexe il s'agit plutôt d'une blague
doute le geek au plouc c'est bien
entendu un appel amusant il faut mettre
ça au même niveau que l'appel à se
laisser pousser la barbe et d'autres
choses du genre
alors après l'abstinence sexuelle est un
système pileux surabondant la belgique
parviendra-t-elle à sortir de l'impasse
politique
ou faudra-t-il dernier recours prohiber
les frites
c'est maintenant l'heure de n'être
d'infos il leur a fallu un mois tout au
plus pour que les tunisiens tourner la
page ben ali une rapidité qui a surpris
tout le monde et en particulier la
classe politique française dans un pays
largement froid à la censure facebook et
twitter auront été une formidable caisse
de résonance aux aspirations du peuple
tunisien
en egypte la résistance s'organise face
aux coupures d'internet le web acteurs
des révolutions du monde arabe
un reportage de thomas raguet
il aura suffi de 18 jours pour assister
à la chute d'hosni moubarak un mois à
peine pour celle du régime ben ali
des soulèvements populaires aussi
puissant que fulgurant portée et relayée
par internet comme les médias